German how you doing buddy
hey Rich uh glad to be here first time
uh caller what do you got for me today
is it is it German or German like how do
you pronounce that uh German just like
the language it's easier interesting
okay
it's uh Spanish
okay German's easier to remember let's
go with that German okay what do you got
for me bro so uh I'm calling just
because like lately I've been having
issues
um it's more like I guess something that
you said earlier is that maybe I'm too
entitled and I find that I kind of trip
over myself whenever I approach women
sometimes I lose interest like I've seen
my buddy who's you know like a
bodybuilder he gets it he always gets
women that come to him they touch him
they interact with conversation and I've
been trying to elicit that yeah you know
like I'll dress nice
um you know I try to act a certain way
and kind of watch myself
but I guess one example is this weekend
I went to a concert and this woman kept
putting their stuff in my Orbit kept
bumping into me but never once
approached him and
I don't know I I just sometimes I forget
what to do and I just enjoy the moment
and I don't do it so she bumps in you
and then does what does she look at you
and say sorry or does she just
carry out this one didn't this one did
it she was playing hard to get
so hey Evan so let me ask you this
question she bumps into you in a social
event she's attractive you think she's
hot what do you do next like what would
be a better way to handle it than just
oop and you just keep going like what
like what could you do
oh you put on the charm talk to him
smile put on the charm you know you
don't have to bump into me if you want
to talk to me sweetheart
yeah
that's that's a good second time that's
not a coincidence hey I'm rich how you
doing
yeah right and you just kind of roll
from there
so my question is how do I get into that
mindset because sometimes like for
example it'll be the weekend I'll get
all excited want to hang out with the
boys
and then somehow over time as I get
there
I just forget and I lose it and I just
get caught up in the moment and then I
shift mindsets so and okay so like the
mindset shift is what the paas like all
of these guys that sell courses about
dating and buy my course and I'll do
Fields this and that and take you out
and show you how to pick up girls it's
rather than mindset it and turn it on
and off just become the game
whenever you're at a bank at the cashier
and you're checking out just flirt with
a girl
it's called Catch and Release it's just
you know keeping your game up right it's
like you don't have any intention like
it could be a 40 year old gross chick
that you're not even you know like
attracted to but you're at the checkout
you know she looks at you you know hey
how's your day whatever
do you need a bag what whatever she says
who cares just flirt with a little bit
right so you're not having to turn it on
and off and have to deal with like the
inhibition of being Charming or whatever
just always be Charming
right because I mean if that's in your
scope of of things and and if that's
what you want to do you want to put
yourself in a environment where you're
exposed to beautiful women and they are
going to start responding to you my
advice wouldn't be like you know just
turn it on and off whenever you're out
partying with your friends or going
somewhere it's just do it all the time
you're at the bank you know the teller
is cute say something
yeah just become that
just become the game yeah I get that I
am the game you know that's that's what
you have to become it's it's a lot
harder to turn off turn things on and
off it's like trying to turn on you know
good diet and lifestyle habits and then
like one week you know you've got it
down pat your diet's right you're
working out your sleep's on par and then
the next week you don't sleep at all you
eat like you're smashing back
Donuts drive through food right like
it's better just to be consistent most
of the time yeah yeah and to try to turn
it on whenever it's convenient for you
yeah I like that I think uh that's kind
of something where I've been walking try
that slacking I've been practicing I've
not been practicing enough
but anyway I do okay at online dating
apps and we'll get a date
um sometimes second sometimes we'll even
hook up so but imagine how much better
you'll be on real date environments if
you're charming and you become the game
everywhere and everything you do you
have a job to go to there's a
receptionist you go to the dental office
the hygienist is working on you a little
flirt that's not going to hurt anybody
who cares yeah maybe she's married maybe
she's not maybe she's got a boyfriend
maybe she doesn't who cares maybe it
turns into a date just because you're so
Charming you never know yeah right yeah
that would be great I uh I had another
one where my buddy I guess tried to
introduce me to grow and
I was so like dumbfounded I was just
like tears and didn't really talk her
the rest of the night and she approached
me a second time
she said you want to go upstairs in my
mind I knew that it was like a 20 cover
so I didn't I just said no and then that
was the end of that
I just get uh
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out